こんにちははじめしちです皆さんはお寿司
というものをご存知でしょうか私今ですね
すろさんにお邪魔しておりますお寿司と
いうものはですね日本古来から伝わるお米
白い米に酢をかけた酢飯そしてその上に魚
の切り身を乗せて食べるといった回線の
新鮮な味を味わえるお料理お寿司という
ものがあるんですけれども今回来ており
ますこちら寿司ろというお店もですねま
海鮮寿司のトップ全国にある寿司ろって
いうもうお寿司屋さんの有名なお店なん
ですけも僕思いまし
たお寿司ちょ小さいんじゃないかパクパク
食べれるのがま便利といえば便利というか
細かくいろんなお魚食べれるんですけども
回転寿司知った時僕困ったことがありまし
てあのどれ食べていいかわからないんです
よ寿司のネタが多すぎてどれを食べていい
かわからない困ったでですねあのお寿司と
は別の勢力でですねあの海鮮丼というもの
が世の中に存在しまして回線のお米の上に
こう魚の切り身とかその回線のものが
たくさん乗ってるっていうですまいわばお
寿司の合体版なんですよ海鮮
のご弊があったらすいませんなので私思い
ました寿司の全メニューを混ぜて海鮮丼に
して食べたらめちゃくちゃ美味しいんじゃ
ないかスろのメニュー全メニューを合体さ
せて海鮮丼を作って今日は食べてみたいと
思います大きさが心配というわけで今日
ですね特別に家から容器持ってきまし
[音楽]
たこれねちょっと心配だったんですよ
回転寿司でマナー悪いお客様とかたまに
いるかもしれなくてこんなこといいんです
かとスろさんにお聞きしたところあの許可
いただきました自前でめちゃくちゃでかい
海鮮丼用の容器を持ってきて今からスろに
行って全種類の握りを頼みここでこう持っ
て綺麗にして全メニュ合体させて回線のを
作ってみたいと思います本当にいいんです
かスろさんちこれ許可許可取れてるこれ
これ取れてます大丈夫あの皆さん真似し
ないでくださいね俺今から何しに行くかて
とろに行って握り解体して回線丼作るんで
今回特別の許可を得て撮影しております皆
さん絶対真似しないでくださいというわけ
で早速スろの握りを全て混ぜ合わせて作っ
た最強の回線丼作っていきたいと思います
では
[音楽]
行こうはいというわけで早速すろさん行き
たいと思います来ましたよすろ静岡明店に
保存してますここ俺も大学時代から
めっちゃ通ってたスで馴染みがありますね
えスろってそもそもメニューどんぐらい
あったっけ560560とかかななんか俺
もっとあった気がするんだよななんか
サーモンだけでも色々じゃん炙りサーモン
とかさサーモンバジルチーズとかそれも
もうですね全サーモン入れた回線の作って
いきますこれ多作り方とかも大事なんだろ
な行きましょう
[音楽]
かちょうどお昼過ぎなのでお客さんは
かなり少ないと思い
ますはいはいはいはいはいはい
はい俺こんなんでスしろ来たことないよ
早速頼んでいきましょうかメニュー見よう
まず握れですよ
ねどんぐらいあるんだろうこういうのどう
するこのなんかサカ盛りとかそれもお寿司
じゃないですかそうだよなこういう
メニューだもんなはい全部行きます
とりあえず握りをカパスから頼んでいき
ますここういうのってことだよ
[音楽]
ね5皿ずつしか頼めないんでこれで注文し
ますこういう感じで握りどんどん頼んで
いきたいと思います見
てマグロサーモ活用のゾーンでさ1ペジ8
でしょで5ページ
でしょ
4340あるぞ
これでハマチぶり光り物で11個ぐらい
かやばいやばいやばい待ってこれやばい
ぞこれ全部ってことだもんねやばいや
絶対美味しいのよえだって寿司で全部頼ん
だことあるないです無理でしょ夢ですそれ
をですねもう1品にまとめますからもう誰
も見たことない回線の作りますよじゃあ次
頼みますもうどんどん頼んで
[音楽]
いくよはいはいはい行きます
ね
[音楽]
おら
来た来た来
たえうまそううまそう見てもう色が
キラキラこのまま食べ
たいマグサーモンがやっぱ多いです
[音楽]
ねうわすごいベニサーモンバジルレモン色
すごいねでピって音あちょっと待っえっと
あちょすごい止まら
ないピピって音でやりたいもんねちょっと
待って本当になん喋り出しで来るの
[音楽]
やばいまもなくご注文いただきました商品
が到着いたしますもう回線みたいなやつ来
たあやばい次行きました次行きましたこれ
やばいぞやばいぞこれえっともうあのです
ね置き場がですねちょっともうないと言い
ます
[音楽]
かオッケーこれでマグロサモカツオ
シリーズは終了次ははまちぶり光り物行き
ます俺あんまりここら辺頼まないんだよ
[音楽]
[拍手]
なはいきましたよやばいやばいやばい
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
危ねえ
えっともう置けません全然まだ注文するの
で絶対置けないのでちょっと隣のテーブル
も借りてますのでちょっとそっちに移動さ
せ
ますオハマジブリ光り物クリア次エビかに
回エビまで
頼む
待って待って俺食べれないの多い
な
何
ちょっと注文
[音楽]
できるやばいやばいやばいフィーバー起き
とるまもなくご注文いただきました商品が
到着いたします
待ってやばい
結構やばい
やばいまもなくご注文いただきました商品
が到着いたしますえとエビチーズまで頼み
まし
た次はイカタコウギ穴子行き
ます
はいよし
よ作る側と頼む側の今戦いが起きてますま
も
[拍手]
[音楽]
なくまもなくご注文いただきました商品
やばあまずいこれこれまずいよこれまずい
これまずで
やばい
危ねえ行き
ますオこれでこのレン
クリア天ぷら炙りからですねもうちょいだ
ねあと2項目ですすごいよきたね見て
あっち側の
レ全部俺注文したい良かったお客さんが
少ない時間帯
で昼間だったら絶対ぶち切れてたよ店員
さんじゃあ天ぷら炙り行きますここら辺
美味しそうだな炙り上穴食べたい
ありがとうござい
ます休憩ねなかなかこの作業量珍しいよ
書いてんの
し
あれあ来まし
た
あれどこまで行ったっっ
け牛塩カルビチーズちょちょ待って待って
待ってえカルビとかも乗せる回線丼に
ミックスドまそうだよ握りのメニューに
ありますから回線丼ってことでいいですよ
ね大丈夫か
[音楽]
なエビチーズまで頼みまし
たはいあ最後卵そのここら辺も行きますよ
ねくそよ
ね絶対にハムが回ではないえとカプレーゼ
はいはいはいはい
はいいやいややばいてグリル
チキンあと1品かなえ軍とかどう
するどうしますかそうのりってでもさどう
なんですかねでも生ハムとか言ってて乗り
行かなてほくのちょっと申し訳ない確確か
にどうしたいですか1回ちょっと見てみて
いいえでもこういうさなんかイクとかさ
回線に欲しいと思うんだよ
ねてこと
はやばいとりあえず最後頼みますこれねで
こっからちゃんと巻き物も行きましょう
ここ行けばもう全制覇
でしょペン
ポンはいというわけでこれね握りは全
メニュー頼み終わりました確認しましょう
かここねこのランとここ全部頼みました
注文履歴ご覧ください店舗によって握りの
メニュー変わってくると思うんですけども
一応このお店は何個だ全部隅になってるね
50個50皿今届いておりますでねさっき
ほら軍もこみたいな話したでしょあの机見
てくださいこれこっちのお皿
とこっちのお皿とこっちのお皿あの
テーブル3つ埋まってしまいましたあの
ちょっと軍艦がもうスペース的に頼めない
のでとりあえず握りだけ1回ここにまとめ
たいと思い
ますじゃ早速作っていこうと思いますまず
ね回線丼ていうぐらいなのでシの部分を
全部あの抽出してここに土台となるあの酢
を詰めていきます卵があるとし
ます分解して
あのシリだけこっちに置くというこの作業
をちょっとしばらくやっていきたいと思い
ますすごい
なあやばいこれ崩したくねえこういうのむ
ずいね回線の見栄えが大事なのであんまり
崩したくないんだよな
[音楽]
うん謎の罪悪
感はいというけで握りのシリ全部出しまし
たはい結構な量ありますねやっぱりでこれ
お筋の形してるとダメなのでほぐしてもう
普通の酢飯に直していきますせっかく握っ
ていただいたのに申し訳ないでも美味しい
ものができると私確信しており
ますどんの部分なんとなく形できましたで
回線どんどん回線の部分なんですけれども
お皿がかなり多かったのでまとめておき
ましたこちらご覧くださいシリがこんな
感じでこっちにもうネタだけねお皿で
ちょっと軽く分けておきましたこれを最後
にトッピングしていきたいと思います一旦
これ置いとい
て握りだけじゃ終わらせません軍艦も頼み
ましょうどんぐらいあるんかなあけど意外
と少ないねやっぱり回線丼と言ったら
やっぱゆらとか乗せたいのでさすがに頼み
ましょう
[音楽]
いやあもうもう行けるぞねこれもいける
意外と少ないぞ
[音楽]
軍艦絶対裏でさえすごい量の軍官が来
たって絶対焦ってると思うんだちなみに
これあの裏情報なんです
けど先にあの結構前からお店にはご連絡さ
せていただいてますこういうことします
よっていきなり来てねたくさん頼むと絶対
大変だと思うので実はこういう企画する時
はねちゃんと前もって言うんですよ郎さん
ありがとうございます絶対嫌だもんね
こんな突然されたらその日俺バイト入り
たくないいすもんそうだよねあやべあれあ
えっと
あやばい休憩間違えたまもなくご注文
いただきました商品が到着いたします
いくら来
たいくら
いくら
[音楽]
いくらもりのらまもなくご注文いただき
ました商品が到着いたしますいくら
まろ何かわからん
パあ
来まもなくご注文いただきました商品が
到着いたし
ますじゃ多く
ねあお祈りさん忘れてましたこれで軍艦
巻き物全てコンプリート
です結構すごい
ね
はいというわけでグガン巻き物全て届き
ました全部隅になってますねはいちょっと
のりがあるので難しいんですけれどもなん
とかこれをコーディネートして美しい回線
丼を作っていきたいと思いますもう何点
頼んだんだろうわかんないよね多分注文力
50件までしか見れないのでちょっと何皿
分頼んだのか最後になってみないとわから
ないんですけどもとりあえず回線丼完成さ
せたいと思い
ますじゃ作っていきます
で巻かれてるやつ外すのちょっともったい
ないのでちょっと周りをこういう軍もで
囲んであげようかなと思いましてちょっと
スペースも気にしつつ作っていきますこの
らのポイント
はこういうなんかキュウリ飛び出てるやつ
があるんですけど1個ずつ空間開けながら
置いてきますもうキュリ出てるの
ないもうないですああ終わりましたここ
まで
です
やばいこれさ難しくね結構この量でやる人
初めてす
もんちょっと軍艦のさばき方が非常に
難しいですよね二重にしていきましょう
周りこういうことだよね多分うんゆらは
残しときたいかな巻き物系を
ねお上から見ると綺麗すねあ本当にはいえ
めっちゃ良くないなんかめっちゃいいっす
ようんこれで軍系はほぼ終わりましたおい
さんは僕食べてき
ますはいというわけで軍艦系が給終わった
のであはもう本当に握りのネタをいかに
綺麗に置いてくかだと思います見て
ください握りのネタの勝やばいのよ
もうあれをいかに色取れるかはもう僕の
センス次代なので頑張っていきたいと思い
ます行きますまずこのちょっと高級っぽい
やつだねマグロとかは絶対多いから外角
マグロで埋めたくないで多分すごい多いの
でちょっとこ重ね目で置いていきたいと
思い
ます
合ってるよね多分うんいや何を持って合っ
てるかわからんけどなるべく色が一緒な
マグロを置いていきたいねなんか絶対これ
高いやつだろうなまこの際にネタの値段
関係なく綺麗に行けるかどうかなうんこれ
何の回線とになるんすかね値段やばいだろ
ねここからこっち側サーモンで埋めたい
ですサーモン多いねやっぱりスろといえば
サーモンのイメージがあるから
なうんまこんなもんじゃないかな外見
はこれ全部使った方がいいよね見たいです
ねですよねお願いします分かりましたもう
1周してき
ますこのトマトとか乗ってるのもね
しっかり乗せていき
ましょういろんな部分で味が違うのが
でかいアバカごと行こうとしたんですけど
やめときまし
たやば赤身の魚だけでも何周してんだ
これどうでしょう素晴らしいですだいぶ
まともかなうん綺麗なんか天ぷらとかある
じゃん卵とかちょっと回線じゃないものは
このスペースここ開てるのでここに置いて
いきたいと思います卵とかねもう俺ここで
いいと思ってんだ
よ卵いいっすね色がね映えるよね
オッケーあとはこの中心街をいかに美しく
彩れたかだと思います頑張り
[音楽]
ます
はいというわけでスろさんの全握りそして
軍艦巻き物を使って作った海鮮丼できまし
たいやもうもりもりのも綺麗な置き方かは
わかんないんですけどもなるべくちょっと
縁を意識してなんか綺麗に鮮丼ぽく持って
みましたであのすいませんあの乗せれ
なかったのも一部ありましてあの色合いと
か考えるとやっぱこういうお肉とかハムと
かはちょっとどうしも乗せれなくてこれ
ちょっとここにこういう感じね添えさせて
いただいてまサイドメニューですどうです
かなんか穴子とかサーモンマグロがやっぱ
多かったかななんか軍ののり取って乗せる
のもなんかちょっとあんまり綺麗じゃない
なと思って逆にそのまま乗りのまま周りを
こうコーティングさせていただきました
個人的には結構綺麗にできてる方だと思い
でまお肉の他にももっとたくさんネタが
あったんですけどもちょっと全部乗せれ
なくて下とかに結構入れたりしてなんとか
なっておりますちなみにこの回線丼を作る
のにかかったお皿の数153皿そしてこの
回線丼の
金額
2940皆さん2万5000円の回線です
よでもねもうスろ全部美味しいから絶対
美味しいのよマジで味は保証された本当に
美味しい海鮮のだと思うので早速食べて
いきたいと思います海鮮丼ということなの
でねどんぶりによって食べていきましょう
どこ食べても美味しいな
これどうしようかなええなんかせっかく
作ってるのに壊すのやだなまでもそれが
海鮮頓というものですからなるべく崩さ
ないように食べ
[音楽]
たいああでもこの食べ方いいはいはいはい
はいこれはお寿司だとできない食べ方です
からいただき
[音楽]
[拍手]
ます
うん
うまい出ろ
[音楽]
だ
うんうんなかなかどんぶりで寿司ろのお
寿司食べることないと思うのでこれは貴重
な経験ですねで混ざっててもめっちゃ
美味しい
です
多い
なまもなく
[音楽]
ご
みな